hey guys just Xena this is ro no so
today we're doing something a little
crazy you might see it here on the table
it is called duty hen I'm two years old
so this is really funny it's like a game
where we throw poop at each other
doesn't work as we filmed a really fun
video for ROS channel no crew involved
no but what did he do we tried a bunch
of different gadgets we had done another
a part one video a little bit ago but I
guess so we were requests from you guys
to do another one so we did a part two
and then something that you guys didn't
request this is actually a gift from my
friend Edie she bought me just meeting
like five years ago and it is been
sitting in my closet ever since I mean
why not put on hats and to improve it
each other
don't be what are these you put this on
your head it's velcro I mean this is
going to be absolutely ridiculous and
there's different scores so on the side
oh right down the middle
that's the bullseye gasps a hundred
points I think there's a bunch of
different things and different ways you
can play this but I think how we should
play it let me a quick sit across from
each other is broken for each other
let's just like put these on we'll throw
through on each other's head this is
ready
did we look good the answer to that is
always yeah so here's our little piece
this looks like a pretzel this one looks
like a cookie poop pile of poo nakulan
are you ready around number one yeah
laughing look I already got 100 points
[Music]
I'm it okay so I've got 193 points you
know one over here you wanna jump can I
just say that there's like bag o or
cornhole oh yeah I'm not very good at it
I hit you in the face okay
oh good okay okay one more we got it
wasn't worth a pound of pretzel food
hey I didn't I did okay there's a 50 I'm
going for 100 oh okay
which would you get 50 50 I just saw
something targets it look 200 200
we're going at that maybe I could you
like a bounce shot off the wall round
number two okay
through the shot did it work no it
didn't at all if you can get the
[Laughter]
backslid I got it 150 need a squeeze my
little ooh I've been practicing juggling
can I get better
oh no not not and no fun at all he's
supposed to work I didn't listen a
juggle with these because these are very
difficult
yeah I'm gonna go for that 200 so I'm
gonna try to get to do the bow down the
middle on the back like this yes I
should not move I know I admit I think
it's completely ready I'm sorry I was
trying to okay and yeah you could get it
I'm gonna go for big money
Oh
and now we just want we want to take
babies a little present what what would
you know oh okay that's alright I'll
have my glasses on and what Deptford
this was it my best effort I'm sure dips
in this swill off so what did you get a
hundred yeah I got a hundred so maybe
for this one we sit backwards oh I can
get a chance to get the 200 let's do it
so I miss it around backwards in my
chair I'm sick bastards ate my chair I'm
ready I'm not gonna move
it's so close to me like oh oh it's
actually a little bit more divided was I
was a little oh I got 200 400
come and check your mouth
oh yeah all right I'll get in this one
row turn
yeah here we go well Gary you're hanging
on by a thread so um I'm gonna I'm gonna
go quick before you get up oh I get it
300 you get another one cuz you don't
have your reading glasses go ahead try
again it's good right yay that is 200
Jesse message I got an idea for a final
round I have a really big food pleasure
and I'm wondering though what sticks
with it we'll find out and it sticks
well how many points do we get a
thousand okay
[Laughter]
what uh yes I ordered this online and
it's funky like right boys yeah yes I
love him he's incredible he has been
doing this since with the very very
beginning and he is the original creator
of the emoji pillows so all the other
ones are ripoffs to avoid is the
original heart oh we love you we're
gonna try this Pooh plushie with this
velcro
ah three tries okay I don't know oh no I
wasn't landed and didn't move
yes it's too big here you can try it
come on
okay we go up and okay because I think
if I can get to your lands flat bit like
this it just lands there oh yeah I'll do
it as it is it yeah okay let's try just
me high on the top one to 600 just feel
so wrong because she's my girlfriend and
I'm just throwing poop Asian I mean this
is so like little monkeys would do
actually yes like I feel like in the
amber Kingdom these are the monkeys is
how they play they're like oh how you
doing but then actually what they do do
I think you do
ah this is great well thank you so much
for playing the bouquet would say
because I've been trying to do this
really five years that's it we
successfully play doodyhead now we got
to figure out who the ultimate duty
headed let's tally the scores
it looks like I have 700 and I have 550
so you beat me by 150 you are the winner
of the duty head game congratulations
look at this I thought when you wear
your mama side oh she looks like
Princess Leia and if they were little do
these by little duty bun if you put in
the middle look it's a poof unicorn
I'm a poo nakorn I love it
well thank you guys so much for watching
if he joins it completely just
absolutely random video I've had this
for so long I'm so excited I can't think
of anybody else better to make this
video is we did good we have fun I mean
I'm just really excited to be the
ultimate beauty head like I'm going to
change our Twitter bio to incredible
honor gonna be so impressed it's a new
title make sure you guys go to her
channel and check out the video that we
did over there we were testing out
Japanese gagik gadgets yeah so silly
mmm is great so go check that up check
out rope cozy high and now we're going
to take off the two heads and go live
our life see you later
[Music]
you